[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Patrick caner bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation sénateur du
Nord président du groupe socialiste ici
au Sénat on est on commence évidemment
par la loi immigration et l'Assemblée
nationale qui a donc rejeté hier le
texte avant même d'avoir commencé à
l'examiner est-ce que vous viez ça comme
une
victoire c'est une je dire une forme de
de défaite pour le bon
fonctionnement de nos institutions euh
une victoire politique
inédite
aussi c'est un voyez je suis partagé
vous le sentez dans mon propos un
partager entre la satisfaction de voir
un
texte mauvais dégagé du débat parlementa
dans des formes encore une fois très
originales mais je vois aussi
les réactions des uns des autres qui
consistent à dire c'est le mariage de la
carpe et du lapin entre le Ren d'un côté
et la gauche de l'autre qui a abouti à
cela c'est surtout une défaite
personnelle pour monsur juste pour
revenir là-dessus on va parler de
géralin Géral daranin justement il dit
c'est l'alliance des contraires qui se
sont mis d'accord pour des raisons
politiques à est-ce qu'il a pas raison
mais qu'est-ce que voulez que je vous
dise monsieur Darmanin a joué la
confusion il a perdu quand ici au Sénat
pendant une semaine il a dhanisé le
texte euh en donnant des gages en
permanence à LR pour avoir un vote
positif qu'il a obtenu en faisant
supprimer le fameux article 3 et
l'article 4 sur l'intégration par le
travail en durcissant la circulaire Vals
qui permettait quand même cette
régularisation pour des gens de bonne
volonté qui n'ont envie que de
s'intégrer dans notre pays en supprimant
le l'aide médicale d'État en en
associant à 50 présences sur le
territoire des gens qui pourraient
obtenir dans l'avenir des allocations
familiales en fait rappelez-vous le
propos de Monsieur Darmanin qu'est-ce
qu'il avait dit il avait dit nous serons
gentils avec les gentils méchants avec
les méchants à la fin du texte on était
devenu méchant avec les gentils et puis
méchant tout court donc il a donné des
gages ici au Sénat et puis bomm
changement de d'attitude changement de
décor à l'Assemblée où là il dit mais
finalement le texte du Gouvernement
initial est très bien donc il a créé la
confusion c'est l'arroseur arrosé la
confusion a été sanctionnée hier et puis
moi je vais vous dire j'aiété très
choqué ce weekend j'ai reçu cette lettre
voilà monsieur le sénateur canner euh
enfin c'est un communiqué de presse
transformé en lettrre avec les fameux
exemples vous savez euh une lettre de
qui juste de Monsieur Darmanin donc un
communiqué de presse qui m'est envoyé et
en fin de compte la Voix du Nord chez
moi l'a reçu très très tardivement donc
c'est un communiqué de presse qui était
une lettre adressé au parlementaires
donc tous les députés l'ont reçu mais
aussi les sénateurs avec des exemples en
disant disant mais finalement si ce
texte n'est pas adopté bien vous serez
responsable des viols des des attaques
au bien des CRIM causés par tous celles
et tous ceux que avec cette Toie je
pourrais expulser donc si vous ne la
votez pas vous serez quelque part
responsable de ce qui va vous
arrié honnêtement quand j'ai reçu ça je
me suis dit c'est un
feake donc j'ai téléphoné j'ai téléphoné
directement à l'attaché parlementaire
monsieur Darmanin qui était un peu
interloqué qui ne savait pas que cela
existait et pourtant c'est un marqué
communiqué de presse du ministère de
l'intérieur elle a vérifié elle m'a
envoyé un texto je pourrais vous le
montrer mais bon voilà disant non non
vous disant que c'est bien géralin qui a
écrit qui a écrit et tous les députés et
tous les parlementaires de France ont
reçu la même lettre donc une grande vous
l'z VC comment de la maladresse une
forme de pression c'est une pression Mo
moi je je l'ai ressenti comme une
pression et j'ai le sentiment que même
des parlementaires proche de Monsieur
Darman ont dû dire mais ça va trop loin
le mieux est l'ennemi du bien et là on a
voulu poussé puis monsieur Darmanin
était manifestement très sûr de son coup
et puis patatra c'est c'est tombé donc
donc pour vous c'est un échec de la
stratégie politique de géralin il est
personnellement responsable de ce qui
s'est passé hier pour vousoui oui parce
que toute l'idée toute l'idée de
l'équilibre du
texte initié par Gérald darin et Olivier
duopt qui avait disparu totalement
rappelez-vous la vie de recherche que
nous avons lancé pour savoir mais où est
le ministre des affaires sociales toute
cette idée d'équilibre qui m'a été
présenté comme président de groupe par
les deux ministres fin décembre enfin
décembre 2022 en disant voilà le texte
qu'on va présenter on
l'incarne du sopte pour la partie entre
guillemets sociale moi pour la partie
régalienne et on va porter ce texte
ensemble finalement du SOP bom évacué
pour des raisons d'ailleurs diverses que
que vous
connaissez darmana se retrouve tout seul
au banc quasiment tout seul au Sénat il
est devenu le cador de ce texte et bien
le cador est tombé euh hier donc moi ce
qui me vienne le plus le chque de
Monsieur Darmanin est-ce qu'Emmanuel
Macron a eu raison de refuser C
démission pour vous B vous savez
peut-être que Monsieur Macron préfère
avoir monsieur Darmanin euh sous euh sa
main que de le voir à l'extérieur enfin
Monsieur Macron est un maître en la
matière euh même sil est le timing n'est
pas le même il a quand même quitté le
gouvernement pour pouvoir être libre de
pouvoir monter sa son aventure et il l'a
monté il a gagné peut-être qu'il a pas
envie de voir Monsieur Darmanin revenir
dans le Nord se ressourcer et commencer
à à gérer ses intérêts personnels vous
lui demandez de démissionner vous
certains parlementaires de gauche récl
sa démission est-ce que c'est votre cas
très honnêtement moi je ne demande
l'mion de personne il a pris sa
responsabilité en présentant cette
démission je crois qu'il a bien
fait le président la refuse il est
affaibli enfin Monsieur Darmanin est
aujourd'hui très affaibli et quand quand
il va revenir devant le Sénat si c'est
la solution qui est adopté ce sera plus
le même Darmanin donc le la forme de GA
qui était la sienne de de certitude
incarné tout ça tout ça est fini
monsieur Dara a pris un coup sur
vraiment la figure et un coup qu'il va
payer à mon avis longtemps mais c'est un
homme de ressources je lui fais
confiance un homme du Nord il est
résilient et il pourra rebondir mais là
c'est quand même un un échec et derrière
lui c'est quand même l'échec du
gouvernement c'est le sentiment quand
même que ce gouvernement ne peut plus
fonctionner que par des coups de force
je vous rappelle on est à 20 493 20 493
en un an et demi de de gestion de Madame
borne est-ce qu'on va Contin il vou du
débat Gérald armanin c'est c'est le
débat c'est les parlementaires qui on
empêch le débat est-ce que cebat aurait
évité le 493 moi je suis incapable de
vous le dire j'ai l'impression que vous
êtes un peu partagé quand je vous poser
la première question sur la motion de
Reet est-ce que vous vous l'auriez voté
si vous aviez été à l'Assemblée
nationale oui je je je l'aurais voté je
l'aurais voté euh tout d'abord par
discipline avec mon mon groupe si
j'étais membre du groupe à l'Assemblée
nationale je je l'aurais voté mais pas
de de guetté de cœur mais pas de guetté
de cœur je leuris voté parce que en face
ils sont allés trop loin donc à un
moment donné il faut dire STOP il faut
dire stop et ça a été le stop àquis dans
des conditions politiques particulières
mais il fallait montrer à un moment
donné qu'on ne peut pas accepter ce qui
se passe en tant que tel et et la droite
républicaine les LR en particulier ont
montré une grande fébrilité une grande
faiblesse et une perte finalement aussi
de de de sens on pourra évoquer tout à
l'heure si vous le souhaitez le texte si
ti au taillo sur de la Constitution
voilà est-ce que c'est pas quand même un
peu une victoire en trompleuil pour la
gauche puisque maintenant le seul texte
qui reste c'est celui du Sénat qui est
largement durci pour moi c'est pas une
victoire ce qui s'est passé hier je dire
moi je je n'aurais pas explosé de joie
euh à titre personnel ce n'est pas une
victoire simplement c'est le constat
qu'il y a un problème de fonctionnement
euh de la majorité présidentielle
elle n'a la majorité présidentielle n'a
pas de majorité absolue on le sait euh à
l'assemblé et hier c'est en fait le
début d'une forme de d'impuissance qui
se manifeste de plus en plus euh et la
Haute Assemblée chez nous au Sénat
devient le recours euh c'est pas tout à
fait le sens et l'esprit de la 5e
République mais bon voilà c'est ça
montre aussi que Monsieur Macron avec
son en même temps ni droite ni gauche
tout ça n'est plus crédible et ça c'est
très inquiétant pour le pays sur
l'avenir du texte qu'est-ce que vous
espérreer maintenant Gérald darbanin
exclu de le retirer est-ce que vous
demandez la convocation d'une commission
mixte paritaire est-ce que vous demandez
un retour du texte au Sénat pour un
nouveau débat alors tout d'abord je
pense que la meilleure solution ce
serait qu'on
arrête lu dit ce matin il faut le
retirer il faut il faut tout il faut
tout refaire il faut tout réécrire
écoutez c'est c'est c'est un on est sur
du sable
mouvant il faut arrêter
voilà depuis le début il fait une erreur
en ne retirant pas depuis le début
depuis le début nous avons dit mais
comment cela peut fonctionner avec une
partie du texte entre guillemets
intégratrice sociale et une partie donc
de fermeté de dureté pour ne pas dire
bon donc c de partisl ne fonctionnent
pas ensemble il fallait avoir deux
démarches différentes c'est l'éche du en
même temps aussi ce qui s'est passé oui
et et et l'échc encore une fois deune
forme de certitude déplacé par rapport
aux besoins des Français mettant le
doigt sur les immigrés responsable de
tout oui il y a des immigrés qui posent
problème dans dans ce pays mais il y a
des Français de Souch entre guillemets
qui posent aussi problème donc on a
voulu stigmatiser une partie ben de de
de celles et ceux qui font la France y
compris historiquement euh donc ça a été
une volonté de montrer ses muscles et
qui aujourd'hui abouti à un genou de de
Monsieur Darmanin et de la majorité
présidentielle mais qu'on comprenne bien
est-ce que vous demandez le retrait du
texte ou est-ce que vous lui demandez de
retravailler sa copie parce qu'il faut
une loi iméigrationi moi je pense qu'il
faut retirer le texte et réécrire tout
donc il faut quand même une loi
immigration il faut une loi immigration
il compris dites pas on retire le texte
il y a pas besoin d'une nouvelle loi non
mais moi je suis je la gauche de de de
responsabilité de gouvernement euh la
gauche a pris ses responsabilités
notamment avec les circul Vals quand
nous étions au pouvoir il y a pas si
longtemps la question de de de la
régularisation systématique je n'y suis
pas favorable la question d'une
régularisation pour les gens qui bossent
j'y suis favorable donc oui il y a il y
a des chantiers à mener y compris pour
pouvoir expulser des gens dangereux plus
facilement que ce nit le cas simplement
c'est le mélange des gens on on a créé
une alchimie qui ne tourne pas qui ne
tourne pas et donc voilà ça a pété
excusez-moi à la figure de Monsieur
Darmanin Emmanuel Macron demande à
ellisabeth Borne et à Gérald Darmanin de
faire des propositions pour lever les
blocages est-ce que vous êtes prêt vous
à travailler avec eux pour lever ses
blocages je ne suis pas pour la
coconstruction euh voilà il y a un
exécutif il a un législatif chacun doit
être dans son travail dans son métier on
n'est pas là pour être les supplétifs du
gouvernement quand on est dans
l'opposition bah voilà les choses sont
simple par contre si on est consulté
bien bien sûr qu'on dira ce que ce qu'on
pense on a des propositions en la
matière donc il n'y a pas de difficulté
mais que le gouvernement assume ils sont
partis sur une mauvaise voix ils se sont
crachés dans une impasse absolu voilà il
faut en tirer les conséquences revenir
devant le Sénat mais pourquoi faire on a
déjà un texte au Sénat est-ce que le
Sénat va être entre guillemets plus doux
qu' ne l'a été est-ce que les centristes
vont revenir sur l'amendement Marseille
qui est passé à laattappe d'ailleurs
comme Monsieur Marseille puisque
monsieur Marseille avait disparu aussi
lui du du Sénat pendant 4 jours on l'a
plus vu donc donc je ne sais pas sécrasé
face au LR c'est ça monsieur monsieur
Marseille clairement voulait voulait
résister à LR et finalement tout est
parti voilà et tout tout s
délité pardon et Monsieur Marseille
lui-même n'était plus présent
physiquement dans
l'hémicycle une fois que son amendement
a était écarté au profit d'un nouvel
article sans rentrer dans les détails
qui a été imaginé du texte on a pu vu
monsieur Marseille donc bon on l'a revu
et heureusement sur le fameux texte de
Monsieur rotaillot cette proposition de
loi constitutionnelle qui était à
l'ordre du jour du Sénat C ce soir où
les alr demande une modification de la
Constitution pour qu'il y a un
référendum sur l'immigration et pour
qu'il y ait une primuté du droit
national sur le droit européen en
matière d'immigration l'lr et la
suppression du droit du sol et
l'assimulation plutôt que l'intégration
enfin c'était uNEX que Monsieur Le Pen
père père aurait pu signer c'est un
texte j RN pour vous ah ben du Front
national même alors là si le RN ne
votait pas ce texte là je sais pas ce
qu'ils auraiit voté donc oui c'est pour
moi c'est un texte d'extrême droite de
droite extrême enfin pour ne pas choquer
monsieur rotillot monsieur sootti le
retire à l'Assemblée nationale c'était
le même texte retirer à l'Assemblée
nationale du du du débat ici la chute
est la même on retire le texte qui a été
d'ailleurs déshabillé en commission par
les centristes voilà et et manifestement
monsieur rotillot et ses amis politiques
ont considéré que ce soir il n'y aurait
pas eu une majorité pour le voter donc
ils n'ont pas pris de risque ils ont
bien fait pour vous de le retirer ou
vous auriez souhaité quand même aur bien
fait de pas le
présenter avant de le retirer j'aurais
mieux fait de pas présenter et peut-être
d'accepter la proposition que j'avais
faite d'utiliser la Constitution
c'està-dire que moi j'ai saisi
officiellement monsieur Larché en lui
disant manifestement ce texte pose des
problèmes juridiques d'ailleurs qui ont
finalement été constaté par la
commission des lois et ça ça aurait
mérité une analyse du Conseil d'État
monsieur Larcher a interrogé comme c'est
prévu par les textes monsieur rotaillot
qui a dit non non on demande pas
l'analyse de conseil d'État et moi je me
souviens que Bruno
rotaillot me disait ah oui mais j'ai les
conseillers d'État qui ont travaillé
avec moi sur ce texte bon patatra donc
honnêtement ça fera moins de bruit ça
fera moins de bruit que le le la motion
de rejet à l'Assemblée nationale mais
c'est quand même pas très glorieux ni à
l'Assemblée ni au Sénat que le groupe LR
porte les textes qu'il finissent par
retirer voyez c'est un problème d'image
pour le Parlement il faut du sérieux il
faut du sérieux et là on tombe dans la
caricature et moi je souhaite que sur
les sujets aussi importants que que que
celui de l'immigration et bien on a une
approche sérieuse constructive
raisonnable raisonnable et là on est en
train d'être vraiment dans la caricature
pour élargir le sujet Emmanuel Macron
veut un rendez-vous avec la nation en
janvier pour rappeler la France à
elle-même à ce qu'elle est il veut
envoyer d'un message d'unité à un pays
fracturer il a raison écoutez est-ce
qu'après le grand débat est-ce est-ce
qu'après les conventions citoyennes
est-ce qu'après le Conseil national de
la refondation est-ce qu'après le
conclave de de Saint-Denis en je sais
pas ce qu'il va nous inventer encore
quoi si le grand rendez-vous avec avec
la nation c'est la dissolution bon au
moins là ça c'est cohérent vous l'
demandé la dissolution vous la souhaitez
enfin en tout cas moi je crois qu'on
peut pas continuer comme ça à vivre à
coup de 493 on va pas avoir 5 budgets du
pays à coup de
493 c'est quand même dramatique enfin
nous on travaille là entre nous je vais
vous donner un exemple pour que nos
auditeurs soient bien bien comprennent
bien ce qui se passe hier on a passé le
budget de du sport de Madame oua
casterra nous avons été amenés monsieur
Savin pour LR et moi-même pour le groupe
socialiste à demandé à Madame oua
casterra est-ce que l'amendement visant
et que nous avons voté proposé par
Monsieur Savin est-ce que l'amendement
visant à déplafonner les taxes pour
financer le sport qui amène une
trentaine de millions d'euros en plus
pour le sport est-ce que cet amendement
qui a été voté au Sénat vous allez le
garder dans le cadre du 493
donc des parlementaires le droite et le
gauche du Sénat sont amenés et c'est
surréaliste à se dire mais est-ce que
notre amendement va passer la barre du
493 que vous allez quoi qu'il arrive
utiliser à l'Assemblée
nationale enfin le Parlement là est
totalement minoré marginalisé on en est
réduit à ça madame réduit à espérer à
espér que dans le futur 493 qui va
tomber la semaine prochaine à
l'Assemblée on puisse passer un
amendement c'est pas c'est pas
acceptable ce n'est pas acceptable on va
parler d'un d'un autre sujet Patrick
canner hier il y a eu une grève des
profs dans un collège dans les ivelines
en soutien à une professeur de français
qui a été menacé pour avoir montré à ses
élèves un tableau du 17e siècle qui
représentait des femmes nues ça rappelle
évidemment l'histoire de Samuel pati
avec notamment l'intervention de parents
d'élèves des rumeurs gabrielal s'est
immédiatement rendu sur place il a
annoncé une procédure disciplinaire à
l'endroit des élèves responsables de
cette situation qui ont par ailleurs
reconnu les faits c'est ce qu'a dit le
ministre il a bien réagi oui au
tolérance zéro avec ses pressions sur
les enseignants al c'était pas un
tableau repant les femmes nues c'était
un tableau sur une scène mythique Actéon
et Dian où effectivement il y a des
nymphes au fond du tableau j'ai regardé
voilà pas par parurisme mais pour
vérifier euh bon donc euh c'était pour
alimenter le cours de cette enseignant
et si j'ai bien compris les élèves ont
dit mais nous présenter des femmes nues
en tout cas c'est NF c'est une
provocation vis-à-vis de notre bon on
sait pas d'ailleurs ce sont des des
élèves de conf musulmane il faut
vérifier tout ça bon pas trop vite dans
dans une enquête qui relève de
l'inspection générale de l'éducation
nationale oui mais monsieur hatal a
raison d'affirmer une fermeté absolue
vis-à-vis de ce qui peut apparaître
comme étant la remise en cause
de ce droit fondamental pour un
enseignant qui est d'enseigner qui est
de transmettre les savoirs avec les
supports qu'il souhaite non ça vraiment
il faut faut paser cela et donc s'il y a
des sanctions elles sont les bienvenus
en la matière on a également appris que
le préfet du Nord avait décidé de mettre
fin au contrat àiant le lycée musulman à
veres situé à lî à l'état contrat avec
l'État l'établissement n'aura donc plus
de subvention le motif c'est que le
contenu de certains cours comme le cours
d'éthique musulmane serait contraire aux
valeurs de la République que pensez-vous
de cette décision alors tout d'abord
c'est n pas que des subventions qui qui
vont tomber c'est aussi les enseignants
pris en charge par l'Éducation nationale
donc ça veut dire que le le
lycée devient un lycée sans contrat et
il va avoir beaucoup de difficultés à
fonctionner sans avoir ce que n'est pas
souhaitable des des des subventions
venant d'ailleurs des parents ou
peut-être bon de de pays étrangers ce
qui était aussi un des reproches qui
avaient été fait au moment de
l'ouverture de du lycée mais c'est une
bonne décision ou pas c'est une décision
qui a été prise d'abord par suggérée par
la commission d'agrément de l'éducation
nationale où il y a des élus qui sont
qui sont présents il y a maintenant une
dizaine de jours confirmé par le
préfet il faut savoir que les les
membres les dirigeants du caves vont
engager une procédure devant le tribunal
administratif pour faire casser la
décision
administrative du du préfet donc on est
parti pour quelques mois selon quelques
années de dure ce qui est certain c'est
c'est exceptionnel ce qui s'est passé il
est clair qu'il y a eu des
maladresses que notamment au départ il y
avait des liens dit-on avec l'if donc
avec un organisme proche des Frères
musulmans aujourd'hui est-ce que ce
lycée vit dans des principes contraires
à la République c'est ce que dit le
préfet c'est ce que dit aussi Monsieur X
Bertran le président de de la région des
Haut- France il dit ça fait plus de 6
ans que j'ai alerté l'État sur la
présence de ferl jeux dans dans cet
établissement lui lui salue un signal
clair vous non
moi j'attends que la procédure aille
jusqu'au bout très très honnêtement moi
je connais des dirigeant du du lycée
avrez je sais que c'est un un lycée
d'excellence qui a très bon résultat au
bac il faut le savoir s'il y a eu des
dérapage et bien moi je préfère que ce
soit une enquête judiciaire qui qu'il
qu'il constate queun simple enquête
administrative le préfet a pris ses
responsabilités je les respecte mais je
respecte aussi les dirigeants d'avos qui
demande à ce que la justice passe en la
matière on va parler du PS pour terminer
ce weekend Daniel conbendit a plaidé
pour une alliance aux européennes entre
les socialistes les verres et les
radicaux de gauche avec pour tête de
liste Raphael gluxman qui était votre
tête de liste aux Européennes dernières
vous êtes d'accord avec ça vous aussi
vous souhaitez cette alliance
ah que que Monsieur con Bendit qui est
issu de la gauche comprenne enfin que
Monsieur Macron n'est ni de gauche ni de
gauche mais le droite et le droite ça me
fait plutôt plaisir mais jamais tard
pour bien comprendre la situation
politique il a été séduit con Bendit
comme beaucoup é suivi par Macron la
séduction finit par s'arrêter donc il
revient au berkaille il souhaite une
alliance entre les socialistes et les
vert qui n'aura pas lieu euh et les
radicaux de gauche les radicaux de
gauche vous leur tendez la main al moi
je pense que la liste que nous allons
porter que nous allons soutenir puisque
elle sera pilotée Surel toute
ressemblance par rapael gluxman il faut
qu'elle soit de plus grand rassemblement
possible et je pense qu'on peut passer
cette barre symbolique des 10 % bon ce
qui nous permettrait d'avoir une
douzaine d'élus je le souhaite je le
souhaite % et vous pensez avoir plus de
10 % avec autant de liste à gauche parce
qu'il y aura les verrs il y aura les
ensoumis il y aura les communistes je
crois vote utile je pense que les
insoumis feront peut-être moins que ce
qu'ils avaient
imaginé les vers ont toujours sont
toujours comptés c'est une élection
proportionnelle à un tour tout le monde
se compte euh moi j'aurais préféré qu'il
y ait une alliance entre les ver et les
socialistes parce que nous portons le
même projet politique pour l'Europe une
Europe plutôt à tendance fédéraliste à
caractère social euh donc oui je jeis
encore une alliance avec les radicau de
moche oui ça pour vous c'est pas je je
crois que ce ce n'est pas terminé après
il faut voir les conditions demandées
par monsieur Guillaume Lacroix le
président des radicaux de gauche il faut
que cette liste soit une liste du plus
grand rassemblement possible et avec une
portée politique qui montre que l'Europe
est utile aujourd'hui l'Europe est quand
même le garant de notre de nos grands
équilibres économiqu et piloté par
Rafael Luxman et piloté rapael Luxman
qui a été un très bon député européen
qui a crevé l'écran pendant ces 5 ans et
donc qui mérite de piloter cette cette
liste mais c'est une liste d'abord
socialiste et donc Raphael gluxman n'est
pas notre faire valoir il il a sa propre
existence politique mais il doit
comprendre que nous sommes là et que les
militants socialistes feront la campagne
un dernier mot puisque il y a toujours
un moratoire quant à la participation du
du PS à laanupe est-ce que vous aussi
comme Gérard Larché vous avez envie de
dire ferme ta gueule à Jean-Luc
Mélenchon c'est pas des mots que
j'utilise en public ça peut m'arriver en
privé euh donc j'espace qui a pris à
Gérard l'arché en tout cas moi je
souhaite que mon parti prenne ses
distances avec Jean-Luc Mélanchon qu'il
la ferme ou pas c'est pas mon problème
permettez-moi l'expression ce qui
m'importe mais il a pas dit tout ce que
beaucoup pensent tout pas ce qui
m'importe c'est que notre vision
politique et idéologique pour le pays
l'emporte sur le bruit la fureur et le
chaos quiespère toujours Monsieur
Mélenchon ce n'est pas ma tasse de thé
voilà c'est dit avec des formes
différentes merci Patrick canner